quando le amiche di ted
di partecipare come relatore devo dire
che ho subito chiesto ma perché perché
proprio io e con un sorriso e una
determinazione incredibile mi hanno
risposto ma certo perché la tua vita e
fuori dagli schemi e la tua energia va
oltre alla passione
e stato uno di quei momenti nei quali
con un brivido nella schiena mi trovo
qualche volta anzi spesso a dove mi
guardare in uno specchio costretta a
guardare in uno specchio e con fatica
tantissima fatica cercare di riconoscere
in una persona che non ha nulla di
quello che ho mai avrei immaginato
diventare nella mia vita è nuovamente io
sono abituato a parlare in pubblico per
chiedere aiuto per i bambini che
soffrono ma ho deciso di accettare per
portarvi oggi un'idea che è quella che
non è idoneo lavoro ma che mio lavoro
adatto a me vi sembra un po strana e
alle mie spalle e da una vita tante vite
non spaventatevi perché non vi voglio
parlare di teorie sull'immortalità o di
teorie trascendentali ma di un concetto
molto vicino molto vicino a me e vedrete
lo sarà anche a voi
in realtà è vero questa mia seconda vita
e tante altre vite sono iniziate con la
morte la morte di mia sorella francesca
che è avvenuto a 14 anni fa mi sembra
tanto tempo ma così come fosse ieri
una volta che mi ha accolto totalmente
impreparata kg ed ernesto la morte di
una persona cara ma davvero nel mio caso
non lo è o per niente nel mio piano
della vita non aveva minimamente pensato
che questo potesse accadere a me lo
pensavo magari per gli altri o magari
nei film ebbene questa morte ha fatto
morire anche a me insieme a francesca
sono morta anch'io con le mie certezze
con tutti i miei obiettivi frantumati
con
il punto di riferimento e insieme alle
mie certezze e morte scomparsa anche la
mia fede e poi l'unica cosa che mi è
rimasta è l'ascolto e la ricerca fosse
la ricerca disperata di lei
e in questa ricerca poi tutto il resto
l'ha scritto il destino e il destino è
stato chiarissimo io avvocato e dando
consulenze legali gratuite ho incontrato
quest organizzazione internazionale che
voleva proprio aprire un ufficio di
raccolta fondi in italia esiste da 50
anni in tutto il mondo e così vedi
questa consulenza legale e sentivo la
necessità di fare qualcosa per gli altri
e iniziali iniziali la mia iniziali la
mia storia di questa esperienza inizio e
divenne sempre più totalizzante
prima la sera poi weekend e poi tutta la
mia vita
ecco questa fu la prima porta la prima a
porta che attraverso la quale uscì uscì
dalla mia scatola una scatola come fosse
accade a molti di noi fatte di
conformismo di obiettivi buoni l'impegno
sicuramente una laurea un mestiere
abbiano attribuito tanti affetti affetti
di sangue
eppure una scatola che mi teneva dentro
è chiusa e non me ne accorgevo aperta
questa porta sono entrati in una nuova
dimensione e il mio piano di vita che
sembrava perfetto davvero perso di ogni
importanza adesso vi metterete a ridere
vi prego di non ridere e devo dire che
ho tentato di eliminare questa slide ma
era troppo tardi perché il paragone
davvero umiliante ma per chi ha visto
questo film sa a cosa mi riferisco
talvolta il nostro piano di vita è così
ben organizzato non c'era non ce ne
rendiamo neanche conto più per
rispondere alle aspettative che hanno
gli altri verso di noi che per le nostre
ispirazioni interiore è davvero veniamo
disumanizzati viviamo quasi come robot
come amo le donne di questo villaggio
che vivevano come delle macchine
beh insomma io non mi non mi ero accorta
ed è entrata già in una nuova dimensione
immaginatevi normalmente come intendiamo
noi il tempo quando guardiamo l'agenda
in ufficio e quando magari pensiamo
pianifichiamo le nostre vacanze lo
pensiamo come una linea
beretta con un inizio una fine e tante
tappe intermedie
viviamo in funzione di un obiettivo e
viviamo in funzione di traguardi non è
questo sbagliato ma questa nuova
dimensione queste queste nuove vite che
ho vissuto queste porte che ho aperto
questa nuova dimensione in cui sono
entrata in questa nuova dimensione ho
imparato che il tempo in realtà è
qualcosa di circolare e non c'è un
inizio e non c'è una fine se non si vive
condizionati da un traguardo non dico
che uno debba vivere una vita
idealizzata bisogna raggiungere
traguardi bisogna raggiungere obiettivi
bisogna essere molto concreti ma non
bisogna vivere in funzione condizionati
da questi e se non si vive condizionati
da questi ci sarà sempre
non sarà un solo inizio non so la fine
ma saranno tanti inizi e tante fini è un
continuo cambiamento
io questo l'ho sperimentato su me stessa
il cambiamento è stato fortissimo è
stato eclatante non c'è bisogno certo di
lasciare la propria famiglia di lasciare
proprio lavoro come ho fatto io e di
andare in prima linea lavorare nei paesi
del quarto mondo ma sicuramente in
ciascuno di noi cambiamento possibile
ed è sempre altrettanto rivoluzionario
vi voglio portare adesso con la mente un
po lontano ma in realtà per farvi capire
quanto questo cambiamento è vicino e
rivoluzionario è possibile
vi siamo ad haiti è un paese del quarto
mondo è uno degli esempi un paese dove
io mi sono trovato a lavorare
un paese dove le condizioni di vita sono
talmente disastrose dove mancano gli
elementi essenziali per una vita delle
persone che li distingua dalla vita
degli animali condizioni così
impossibili che sembrano degli elementi
oggettivi assolutamente ostativi di
qualunque cambiamento
ebbene io questa mia esperienza
personale poteva rimanere intima poteva
rimanere mia poteva rimanere veramente
al limite dell'incomunicabilità eppure
io tutti i giorni o la gioia di
verificare questo cambiamento è
possibile anche là dove elementi
oggettivi sembrano assolutamente
renderlo impossibile e vi racconto di
storie concrete di bambini che io ho
visto nelle strade che sono stati
raccolti come alfred e betty erano
bambini che vivevano nella strada
appoggiati su cartoni abbracciati
agency questi ragazzi sono diventati
grandi si sono laureati in visita al
ministry show nel ora ricoprono delle
posizioni di grandissima responsabilità
come è di un ragazzo che faceva parte di
una gang violentissima in haiti
purtroppo questa è la prospettiva per
tanti bambini rischiava di diventare un
assassino
questo ragazzo è stato accolto nelle
nostre case è diventato un medico e
salva tantissime vite e come oselin una
ragazza che è arrivata a 4 anni nella
nostra casa aveva perso ogni speranza
solo al mondo è cresciuta ha imparato
quattro lingue e guardate la è una donna
meravigliosa è una reggina è una manager
è una maestra di vita è diventata per me
è una maestra di vita non vi sto
parlando di storie che sono storie da
brochure o stare da manuale sono persone
vere persone che ho conosciuto nel prima
enel dopo e non parlo di trasformazione
di vita soltanto nel corpo un bambino
che arriva nostro ospedale vuoi mondo e
che viene salvato nella sua esistenza
compagnia ma parla trasformazione di
vita come quelle che voi avete visto una
nuova vita dove sembrava che non ci
fosse e quando e quanto tu capisci
queste persone sono entrate nel cerchio
della mia vita e sono entrate a far
parte di un cerchio di vita che si è
allargato perché quando questa volta si
è aperta e sono entrate in questa nuova
dimensione
allora ho capito che l'orizzonte non è
più l'orizzonte tuo personale i tuoi
affetti non sono più i tuoi affetti il
sangue
l'orizzonte si allarga e quando tu
capisci di far parte di questo cerchio
della vita diventi permeabile come
l'acqua permeabile nel dare e permeabile
nel ricevere e allora senti di far parte
di un tutto di un tutto nel quale
davvero 6 allo stesso livello con
tantissime persone il
e quando tu senti di far parte di questo
tutto inevitabilmente senti anche di
essere responsabile e in che senso senti
di essere responsabile non è un codice
di condotta non è una regola non è
qualcosa che ti viene spiegato fosse un
inglese più facile dirlo response
ability l'abilità di rispondere oppure
rispondere con abilità
ecco che allora quando sente di far
parte di questo tutto
senti di dover rispondere in modo
naturale ai bisogni che ti ci infondono
alle domande che ti vengono fatte anche
alle tue personali mettendo in gioco
tutti i tuoi talenti tutta la tua
intelligenza e tutte le tue capacità e
questo io l'ho visto e quello che mi ha
straordinariamente catturato
dell'organizzazione per calarlo nel
concreto che sto aiutando quello che mi
piace che non si parla di carità non si
parla di elemosina si parla di
empowerment e di aiutare le persone a
trasformare le loro vite a diventare
nuove e quindi a vivere nuove vite
ecco in questo concetto di
responsabilità
vediamo come nel nel cerchio della vita
la passione sia proprio il veicolo che
amplifica e in questi cerchi in queste
tante vite e volpe il veicolo per
amplificare con i tuoi talenti la tua
intelligenza i risultati traguardi che
ti sembravano meravigliosi ma molto
limitati e ti rendi conto come
incredibilmente riesce a fare cose che
non avresti mai immaginato in un milione
di anni beh non vi auguro e non
necessariamente per fare questo cammino
è necessario fare scelte come quella che
ho fatto io anzi forse non so non sono
sicura se la consiglierei a tutti perché
a meravigliosa ma molto molto faticosa e
quando le persone che mi conoscono lo
sanno bene
quando parlo di precedente vita di nuova
vita sanno bene che il discorso che mi
sto facendo oggi non è un discorso che
ho scritto per te ma è qualcosa che vivo
quotidianamente ma sicuramente
sicuramente
ognuno di noi può aprire le porte farsi
trasportare dalla passione dalla
passione come lucida follia che ti
permette di rompere gli schemi e di
vivere nuove vite nuove dimensioni
quindi i miei auguri oggi è vivete tutte
le vostre vite
fatevi trasportare dalla passione